we got big news ladies and gentlemen oh
and the Press doesn't like this theas
Swami announced he will not participate
in the next debate with CNN because CNN
is biased and they're really really
awful and they said nasty things about
them instead we timcast will be hosting
a town hall live event tickets are are
available with Viv we're going to be
doing the timcast town hall with
presidential candidate VI
ramaswami uh at the same time that CNN
is hosting their lesser known GOP
debates uh with Nikki Haley and Ronda
santis so I I love this the media is
just absolutely pissed that V is trying
to go around them so of course they're
smearing him but he announced this
morning and uh uh we're going to be next
week in De Mo on the 10th doing a live
event on stage with vras Swami as we uh
we talk about the current state of
affairs and there's a lot of interesting
stuff that he's uh uh uh talking about
and uh will be talking about so we're
really interested to to have that event
with him it's going to be a lot of fun